un bon soir caleb maupin merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france joe
biden qui veut donc enquêté d'ici à 90
jours il appelle les renseignements
américains à redoubler leurs efforts
pourquoi cette détermination et pourquoi
maintenant
il est important de savoir que l'origine
des pandémies des maladies souvent très
étrange très compliqué il y a beaucoup
de théories différentes sur l'origine
par exemple une pilule du sida d'entrer
le temps on a cru que la syphilis
venez avait été que rapportés en europe
par christophe colomb
mais on sait maintenant que cette
théorie était erroné et que cela
syphilis existait avant le voyage de
christophe colomb jusqu'aux amériques
donc l'origine des maladies est souvent
complexe
en l'occurrence il s'agit d'un effort
politique est flagrant afin de
fiabiliser la chine afin de nourrir une
un récit rendant responsable la chine
sites naturels peu avait ordonné cette
enquête beaucoup auraient dit que
c'était politiques ont redit à raison
que c'était la promotion d'une
rhétorique anti chinoises que la part du
gouvernement
mais comme celle joe biden qui le fait
pour faire plaisir surtout au lobby anti
choix ou l'ouvrant séparatistes
tibétains
parce que jobs ait en sa faveur au le
bain anti chinois alors ils s'en tirent
à bon compte
c'est un acte politique et c'est
dangereux la science doit être de la
science et non pas de la politique
clairement pour vous il s'agit d'un
prétexte à cette demande banque est
présente un prétexte pour nourrir la
guerre commerciale même avec
la chine fait il ya des motivations
politiques désire faire porter à la
chine
le chat potté retombées économiques des
erreurs de gestion du gouvernement
américain la chine à cela le pauvre
avant tous les autres pays du monde
parce que la chine à traiter nos médias
les ont dépeint comme un état très
inquiets d'une dictature
aux etats-unis le président n'a même pas
pu vous obliger à porter des masques
chaque état a développé sa propre
stratégie et la gestion était
catastrophique pourquoi parce que dans
ce pays nous n'avions pas tous le même
programme le système du marché libéral a
des intérêts différents
et cela déchire la gouvernance du pays
cette traction chaotique a eu un impact
dévastateur sur l'économie du pays
plutôt que de parler des problèmes de
gestion de l'incompétence des chefs et
steyn au mieux on préfère développer une
théorie du complot disant que tout cela
c'est la faute de la chine
donc c'est un scandale et on détourne
ici le processus politique
joe biden quand ils demandent cette
enquête est ce qu'il s'attend à voir de
vrais résultats parce qu'on a vu les
enquêteurs de l'om ait enquêté en chine
ce n'est pas forcément évident donc été
là bas
donc est ce qu'il y aura vraiment un
résultat tangible
le fait aucun doute quels que soient les
résultats certains ne les accepterons
pas en fonction de leurs programmes
politiques ya le fait que cette enquête
et étaient commandés nourrit d'un
programme politique
c'est la mauvaise approche le fait que
nous ayons sa conversation à propos du
laboratoire de buran cela montre qu en
dessous de la surface non pas seulement
aux états unis dans le monde entier des
gens se rendent compte de la dangerosité
du concept de la guerre bactériologique
plutôt que d'essayer de rejeter le blâme
sur les autres plutôt que de promouvoir
des thèses karl autistes la communauté
internationale devrait se fédérer et
interdire la guerre bactériologique les
armes biochimiques
si quelqu'un si un pays à sésame alors
l'autre pays va essayer de les
développer afin de mettre en place une
politique de dissuasion et cela met
toute l'espèce humaine en danger il est
probable d'après les données existantes
que ces expérimentations sur des hommes
étaient à l'origine des deux lacs au 19
mai toutes ces théories montre que l'on
comprend bien aujourd'hui ce que et
stewards raconté un siècle dernier et de
plus en plus probable est que plus en
plus vrai les armes biochimiques sont un
enjeu les armes bactériologiques sont
dangereuses et tous les plus grands pays
du monde devraient se rassembler et se
mettre d'accord pour interdire la guerre
bactériologique
car c'est une rue près du damoclès
au-dessus de l'espace qu'on aime et il
faut se rendre compte aujourd'hui
concédé un danger potentiel et
l'interdire à l'avenir alors revenons
à nos moutons cette enquête si la thèse
de la fuite deux laboratoires étaient
avérés par cette enquête
c'est une supposition quelles
conséquences qu'il pourrait y avoir sur
pékin on s'est peut-être une deuxième
arrière pensée de john dryden de pouvoir
affaiblir la chine par d'éventuelles
sanctions je ne sais pas il dit
en effet cela rendra service programme
politique il existe aux états unis de
force
qualifié de lobby chinois certaines
personnes accusent par exemple les
démocrates être au service de la chine
on a fait tiquer truman d'abord perdu la
chine et il ya d'autres exemples dans
l'histoire de des états unis ou la chine
est un sujet majeur
la société est un verre par exemple
juste et des affiches temps tous les
deux lui disant que la chine est à
l'origine du trafic 2 d'héroïne mondiale
alors que la chine en fait agi contre
les opiacés et l'héroïne
donc il y à une faction au sein du
gouvernement américain qui est obnubilé
par la chine la considère comme le grand
ami et alors que l'économie chinoise
prend de l'avancé par rapport à
l'économie américaine qui souffre encore
de l'épidémie pour eux c'est le moment
idéal pour faire avancer leur programme
peter navarro qui n'est prise au sérieux
par aucun économiste leckie siéger au
sein de la migration 30 et été conseillé
alors qu'il a passé toute sa carrière à
blâmer la chine pour tous les problèmes
du monde
c'est un exemple des dangers actuels où
nous avons besoin de coopération d'année
tu y es c'est sur des questions de
développement de changement climatique
et d'autres problèmes auxquels nous
faisons face ce n'est pas la bonne
approche
en tout cas la chine a répliqué en
rejetant l la légitimité de toutes
nouvelles investigations à ce qu'elle
est dans son droit à la chine de dit de
dire ce n'est pas légitime de vouloir
enquêter sur un sur un tel virus qui a
fait autant de morts dans le monde
entier s'étaient pas légitime de vouloir
savoir d'où ça vient
quels que soient les résultats de cette
enquête ont pu s'en servir comme base
électorale est connecté à un peu il
s'organise mais américain donc des
chinois les chinois pourraient rejeter
la faute sur les états unis s'ils ont
prouvé que le virus était parti de
google
et comme je le dit auparavant l'origine
des maladies d'origine et détendue
souvent très étrange et très complexe
scientifique passe des années à étudier
les messages de jeu pid et même
peut-être que nous n'aurions jamais de
réponse peut-être qu'une première
réponse sera démonté plus tard des
boulonnais et il ya des indications que
le coronavirus était en europe qu'on est
déjà en août 2019 peut-être que nous
n'aurons jamais de réponse peut-être que
les réponses seront révisées à l'avenir
la science et la politique ce n'est pas
la même chose et nourrir la politique de
sciences c'est mal merci à calais maupin
cependant d'alerté aux états unis
d'avoir été avec nous